when did the idea for passion flicks
begin Patrick likes the idea of passion
books came about was actually Johnny's
idea Johnny Kane is our family partner
she had the idea of quite a few years
ago she wanted to win fifty Shades of
Grey came out she was wondering why
there isn't a place for us to watch
romance novels that have been turned
into movies when the movie was such a
success so she actually got the URL
pattern fixed calm and said I'm gonna do
this and then many years later nothing
happened to it until one New Year's Eve
she decided I'm gonna make it happen and
she booked a flight to LA and it just so
happened that Joni and I had met a few
months prior to that she had watched a
movie of mine on ion called you cast a
spell on me and she contacted me the
next day and said I have truly loved
your movie I loved how you directed that
movie and I would be I would really love
it if you would take one of my movies
and direct that and normally I you know
you'd get a lot of people that solicit
you and and so normally you just know
I'm gonna ignore that but I couldn't her
note was so sweet and she was just so
open in her communication to me that I
was like okay let me have a look at the
script I read it and I was like she can
really write she's a good writer so
let's meet and then we tried to make
that we try to bring that movie to a
network but no one would buy it because
it was a little too sensual it was a
little too risqué I'd had to do with
magic and that doesn't really work well
with a lot of network television so that
didn't work but when she came over here
that February beginning of February we
sat down and had lunch with our other
partner Gina and over tuna fish
sandwiches she told us that this thought
that she had a passion fix and we went
great
it's a great idea we're gonna do it with
you and we literally started the next
day on founding basically how to create
the company the business plan put
together a full proposal come up with
the idea of how we're going to do all
this and and then
I spent the next few months raising
money and well it was about a year to
raise the money and then option books
and made our first feature last March so
I knew long answer well no that's really
interesting so you had never really you
didn't know Joanie from an attorney I'm
sorry Joan right you didn't know her
previously it was just that initial
email and you just sort of went on a gut
feeling that loudest could be somebody I
want to work with I went oh yes well
writers so the answer is yes I didn't
know Joanie very well at all except for
the communication we'd had on the one
screenplay that she'd written and that
screenplay was good and when you as a
direct I get to work with a screenwriter
and they are they're open to your
comments and your notes and they adjust
the screenplay according to how you see
it as a filmmaker that that
collaboration just forms a deep
partnership to begin with so I didn't
know her personally I never met her in
in person until February but we'd work
together by email and phone calls for a
few months prior to that and so as a
filmmaker I knew her well I see okay so
then you raised was it 4.7 million in
seed funding four point seven five four
point seven five okay okay three okay
okay good to know
so can you just briefly tell us how this
happened did you have specific people in
mind you know you want to approach or
well so that was the difficult part
firstly I'm related to a lot of people
that have raised a lot of money which is
helpful and so I went to them for advice
what do I do
who do you approach and they basically
said everybody you just go to anybody
you just constantly tell what the idea
is to every single person that you meet
and somebody is gonna say hey I have
somebody that might be interested in
that and that's what happened so I
literally just went to every single
person that I knew and I said that had
any ability to to invest and I said this
is the idea this is what I'd like to do
do you have any advice
and would you be interested in coming on
board and some people came on board with
$5,000 some people came on board with
$50,000 so it wasn't they weren't huge
amounts that almost everybody that I
spoke to wanted to participate because
they think the idea is really good I'm
always wondering how that happens is it
a long email is it a phone call is it
when you see them at an event all of
those things so I will take the
opportunity to tell people about passion
flicks every single place that I go so
it'll be at a coffee shop while I'm
wearing a passion flicks t-shirt and I
will tell the people there it will be at
a lunch it'll be at an event it'll be I
do send emails I don't send long emails
because most of the people that you're
dealing with don't have time to read
long emails and they'll ignore them so
shortened to the point with very
specific information in it and what you
want what it is that you're looking to
do what it is you want and I'm happy to
provide you with any further supportive
documents for you to review this that
was basically what I do I'm about to do
it again because we need to do another
race okay so is it similar it's to
raising money for a film or is it are
they two separate animals and sometimes
raising money for a film is it is
different because here I'm raising money
for a company that is a distribution
company that has a overall goal which is
to empower women through emotional
strength while at the same time owns
multiple movies so we are not making one
movie we're making 50 so if you invest
in passion flicks you get a part of all
50 movies that we own forever so should
the company not do well as a
distribution company you still have all
these assets and you're able to sell
them and hopefully we'll make that
$50,000 back I'm purely low so that's
why it's not a difficult ask when it
comes to investment because when you're
looking for an investment in one single
picture it's basically saying hi I have
a movie I want to make I'm gonna spend
three million dollars on this movie can
you give me some money and hopefully
everybody else likes this movie and I
can get a distributor and I can get it
into the theaters or get it into DVD or
so in the foreign market and hopefully
we'll make our money back and then you
can get your 20%
so that's the filming the individual
filmmaking side which is it's a
different beast and there are a lot of
people that want to invest that way
specifically in California or in the US
what I mean is there's tax write-offs
that are involved there's you know all
these different things that are positive
for investors to invest in individual
films but that's all we're looking for
you